peter und ich vertrete heute den
christoph der christoffers mitten im
umzugsstress und deswegen mache ich für
euch heute die klicks und pfeifen ist
mit folgenden themen
wir können bald strecken für die wir
bisher acht stunden gebraucht haben
in nur einer stunde zurücklegen menschen
haben mehr zellarten als bisher
angenommen und droht uns eine neue
eiszeit das sind nur drei der fünf
themen jetzt in den klicks und abhalten
frederik armut kommt aus einem kleinen
stadtteil in der ruby dort gibt es kaum
bis überhaupt keine toiletten kein strom
und kein wasser
er versucht jetzt den 2000 menschen in
seinem viertel zu helfen
die initiative human trust machte sich
zum ziel in kenia bio zentren aufzubauen
menschliche fäkalien sollen dort als
energiequelle dienen in nairobi fehlt
menschen die in vielen orten auf der
welt die möglichkeit ihr geschäft zu
verrichten
auch die nötige energie um zu kochen
oder um einfach nur wasser aufzuwärmen
fehlt vielerorts die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die whu
berichtet dass weltweit noch rund 2 5
milliarden menschen ohne toilette
auskommen müssen
seit jahren versuchen wissenschaftler
forscher und viele mehr dieses problem
zu lösen mit einer sozusagen 21 technik
menschliche fäkalien sollen genutzt
werden um energie zu erzeugen
obwohl schon seit jahren forscher daran
tüfteln eine solche lösung zu finden und
auch schon jede menge vorschläge gemacht
wurden konnte noch immer nicht die
lösung gefunden werden
auch wenn es noch nicht die lösung gibt
nutzen länder wie indien schon seit 1970
eine solche 2 in 1 technik die gruben
technik wenn eine grube voller fäkalien
ist wird sie zugeschüttet und das biogas
wird abgefangen
dieses verfahren hat sich laut so lapp
international social service
organisation bei circa 15 millionen
menschen durchgesetzt
2023 soll es uns menschen möglich sein
strecken für die wir heute noch je nach
wind und wetter ca achteinhalb stunden
benötigen in nur einer einzigen stunde
hinter uns zu lassen
die schallgeschwindigkeit würde dafür
nicht ausreichen sie ist nämlich nur ein
fünftel der macht fünf der sogenannten
überschallgeschwindigkeit genau diese
könnte es uns ermöglichen so schnell
unterwegs zu sein
die us airforce möchten acht jahren ein
solches flugobjekt geschaffen haben
aktuell arbeiten sie zusammen mit der
forschungsorganisation des pentagons an
diesem projekt der x51 waverider das
erste derartige dem flugzeug konnte
solchen geschwindigkeiten bereits dann
versuchen
reichen in der zivilen luftfahrt jedoch
wird diese technologie etwas später zum
einsatz kommen
die airforce konzentriert sich nämlich
auf eine rakete die schnell unbemannt
und mit einem sprengkopf ausgerüstet
keine piloten oder chats in gefahr
bringt das gerät auf den vergessenheit
der vulkan yellowstone wo derzeit noch
im gleichnamigen anten yellowstone
national park in den usa
und das ist auch gut so denn laut
forschern könnte der ausbruch des
vulkans eine wahre katastrophe für uns
bedeuten er könnte unsere erbe in einen
sogenannten vulkanischen winter
versetzen
die temperaturen würden so stark
herabfallen das ganze flächen über jahre
hinweg mit eis bedeckt werden
folge einer solchen eiszeit weltweite
hungersnot am 8 juni 1783 geschah schon
einmal so eine katastrophe
der lucky krater brach aus und spuckte
gewaltige massen an asche und lava in
die luft die partikel der asche bildeten
sich in der luft zu erosionen
schwefelsäure unser vater diese gelangen
dann bis in die atmosphäre und schirmten
nahezu das ganze sonnenlicht ab die erde
bekam kaum mehr sonnenwärme ab über
25.000 menschen sind an den folgen des
starken temperatur falls der ging bis
zumindest 29 grad gestorben
als die aero sohle dann endlich
verschwanden wartete die nächste
katastrophe auf die menschen hochwasser
die sonne erwärmte sich am 23 februar
1784 so stark also sie erlernte die erde
so stark dass die eisflächen in
kürzester zeit schmolzen forschern
zufolge könne eben yellowstone eine
ähnliche katastrophe auslösen noch gut
in einer höhle in spanien wurden reste
eines menschen gefunden der vor 430.000
jahren verstorben war
den tod von dieser laut forschern auf
eine nicht natürliche art es wird von
mord gesprochen
spanische archäologen konnten anhand
einer computertomografie der fundstücke
erkennen dass der mann zwei mal mit
einem gegenstand an der stirn getroffen
wurde
die spuren am schädel des gremiums 17 so
wird der schädel genannt seien vor dem
eintreffen des todes entstanden einsturz
der zum tod führte könne man jedoch
ausschließen dass eher unwahrscheinlich
ist zweimal mit dem kopf gegen denselben
stein oder ähnliches zu treffen
eine häufige todesursache von damals war
der kannibalismus aber auch der kann
ausgeschlossen werden
keine absolut keine anzeichen von
schnitten oder ähnliches seien gefunden
worden
der leichnam wurde in einer schwer
begehbaren höhle gefunden um in die
hülle zu gelangen muss man erst mal 13
meter senkrecht nach unten
mit dem mord könne auch das geheimnis um
diese ungewöhnliche höhle geklärt worden
seien
die forscher gehen nämlich jetzt davon
aus dass die hülle gar nicht als
unterschlupf oder ähnliches genutzt
wurde sondern vielmehr als friedhof
leichen wurden einfach von oben in die
höhle entsorgt revolution in der dna
analyse in us forschungslaboren arbeitet
man in hochtouren derzeit daran bisher
ist man von circa 100 unterschiedlichen
zellarten in uns menschen ausgegangen
mittlerweile könne man dna stränge aber
sogar exakt untersuchen und in rasender
geschwindigkeit analysieren
über 1000 zellen pro tag sollen möglich
sein dass diese lehrbuchmeinung nicht
mehr stimmen könnte
tatsächlich sollen wir menschen aus weit
mehr als bisher angenommen
unterschiedlichen zellarten bestehen
bis da wirklich festgesetzte ergebnisse
erzielt werden müssen wir wohl noch mit
unseren über 1000 zellarten leben jetzt
wäre doch mal interessant zu wissen wie
viele zellarten wie er es super mensch
hätten
mehr zu dem thema und zudem etwas
fiktionalen thema findet ihr hier oben
vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht so
fiktional zu rap und zum block kommt ihr
hier unten und würdet ihr euch in ein
flugobjekt setzen das in einer hyper
schallgeschwindigkeit fliegt schreibt
uns doch mal in die kommentare
ich weiß nicht ob ich das machen würde
und bis dann den spruch gleich den
christoph nicht bis dann